all right hello everyone
so a few weeks ago we had a discussion
about how to write
computational essays and expositions and
somehow that turned into okay
show us how you write one of these for
me so we have a whole bunch of people
here
including many who are quite experienced
at writing things
and uh let's see if we can talk a little
bit about process
for how to write one of these things and
see how much people agree or disagree
about what to do
so we're just talking last couple of
minutes what on earth am i going to
write one of these about so i picked
boolean functions
so my topic is boolean functions now
this is a subject that i know
reasonably well at least that is my
theory
if i didn't know it well i would have to
have an interviewee
to work with because otherwise i don't
know what i'm talking about
okay so the the the what what we're
doing here so
the question is um
so i need some kind of introduction so
i'm going to talk about boolean
functions what are balloon functions
like and and or and so on and so the the
first thing to say
is what's the main point
and you know we have a function in the
language called boolean function
and i think what i'm going to be doing
so i'm just sort of
thinking through and i haven't thought
this out previously
i'm thinking through what um
um let's see so so the basic point of a
boolean function
is it's something that
is is going to take a bunch of boolean
variables
okay so um
um
okay in typical
uh mathematics well
we've got to have the idea of a function
and then the idea of a boolean function
the point of a boolean function is that
its inputs are
combinations of trues and falses so
what's a little tricky is that people
are used to the idea of f of x
or maybe f of x and y but in a boolean
function it's really very common to have
p
q r s many variables
so we kind of have to explain that and
then we have to
um and and why would we care about this
that's another
thing we have to be able to say quite
quickly up front
um and then we might want to give an
example
you know and of true and false and so on
all right anybody got any suggestions
here
um
or am i on my own well in your important
principles of technical writing you say
to uh
sell people on why the feature is
important before diving into it
yes there um
and so i think
um well what is the answer like like i
know roger in his past
life has like analyzed phytoplanes using
boolean functions and things
um in uh um
i think
let's see i think if you want to
bring up it's the foundation of modern
technologies such as digital circuits
um that's a fair point you know and uh
shannon came up with them to systematize
designing
switches meaning phone switches
telephone switches
switching we've got digital computers
digital electronics
um in many
situations well
okay so the question is are we going for
digital electronics
are we going for the more theoretical uh
true
false type type story
um
let's see concrete use case is probably
easier to communicate well it depends
who we're communicating it to
but yes okay so so maybe we want to say
um uh i mean the beginning should be
something and it's always difficult
you know the first couple of sentences
are always difficult
because their way you're kind of saying
what the big point is
um
and so at the core of
computers and other digital electronics
are um circuits
that implement boolean functions
um
in a boolean function
one gives a collection
of 0 1
or let's see zero one
uh one gives a collection of
the input to a boolean function
is a collection of values
that can be either
true slash false one slash zero
on slash off etc
um
the uh
um its output
in the in the simplest form
its output
is a single such value
now again okay so what am i doing here
so one of the tricky things
is an ordinary boolean function of the
kind that the boolean function function
deals with
has this feature that its output is a
single value but now i'm using the fact
that i know
that there's also reversible logic where
you can have two inputs
like an and there's two inputs one
output but i know that they're also
particularly used in quantum frameworks
um also two input two output functions
so i'm trying to
avoid just saying a boolean function has
one output
because in modern times one often
considers boolean functions
that don't just have one output and so
one of the questions is how do you say
that
without confusing everybody i mean you
can be very mathematical
and say um something like uh
um um and say something like
um uh you know it's a mapping from a
set of this that and the other to what
to the single function but that wouldn't
be the right thing to say
so you have to have some way to kind of
uh you know give an indication of what's
going on
without saying the wrong thing um
i think it's it's pretty straightforward
you know
a vector of functions is is you know
means a vector-valued function
um and that's used heavily in all these
applications too not just quantum
computing
fair enough but i'm just saying okay by
the way
um for an alu
with two 64-bit numbers in and the
64-bit numbers out
yeah you know i mean it has well but our
boolean function function is a
one-output
boolean function right yeah but that's
like the primitive from which you build
everything
right um okay well so
okay but when we talk about a function
people's view of a function
is more what you would see in in
calculus or something
where you know it's a function f of x
and y it returns one value
i mean okay yes it can be a
vector-valued function but in the
simplest case it returns one value
okay i'm having a difficulty with this
first sentence what is my difficulty
my difficulty is for those of us who are
old fogies
core was core memory and it's a little
bit weird to say that about computers
here
see what i'm saying so it'd be better to
avoid that possible confusion and people
saying are you talking about core memory
what are you talking about here
um
maybe at the heart of computers and it
sounds a little bit touchy-feely but
um um
now here in a sense it isn't just
electronics
it's probably okay i mean people know
what a circuit is
even though and people have some idea of
what a circuit is even though
it doesn't necessarily the case that
these things are sort of
all uh kind of connected to to feedback
like a circuit does but it's okay
let's let's keep going the input to a
boolean function is a collection of
values that can
either be either now this might be
confusing but i think it's useful thing
to say because otherwise people will be
confused about
you know which of these
okay the input development function in
the simplest form
its output is a single such value okay
so now
an example
a basic example
of a boolean function is and
um okay so now we just say
um now we would say um
and a p and q or
p and and q
or p um
and q uh
is the boolean function is a basic is
let's see
basically you're mixing ands and auras
there
it's not clear if you're using booleans
in your english text
thank you yes i was a good good good
catch
how do we deal with that um
okay and paq alternatively written as
hmm we got another or here
um
it's going to be tough to put together
this without it without a
conjunction which is also bullion
operator
maybe we drop that one there for now
any can you see how to do this eric can
you see how to get rid of
the the boolean thingy there
maybe you could just put the boolean
functions in a different font so it's
obvious which one
or a bold or something so it's obvious
when you're talking about
boolean functions versus the english
word yes well they would naturally be
be in a different font so i mean this
will this will naturally be
um in uh
you could use a serial comma
horrible we've already got commas
running around here
by the way how do we make this so so let
me comment on this
this is going to be code and we're you
know
here arguably we make that into code
like
that because we're already now talking
about something which
can be expressed in wolfram language and
here again
arguably that's true false like that
that's one zero those are you know
orphan language things which can be
written that way and nobody's going to
be confused by that nobody's going to be
confused by seeing that in a different
font
but yet it leads them into the idea that
that's actually representable
computationally
okay is and so and pq so so here these
should be in italics and i'm not quite
sure how to put them
in italics how do i do that actually
does anybody know how do i
if you use control nine for the whole
thing i did use control nine but now i
want to put those
numbers expression i did use it i did
use con
command oh control nine yeah
what would that do put some inline math
okay that's not helping me because i
want this to be
in i don't want that to be in the
uh in the text font you see what i'm
saying
this isn't quite right oh if you just
want to make it italics it's command
i i'm well aware of that i'm well aware
of that look
what we really want to do they used to
be in a different font so i think that's
some recent thing that they
they look like here's what we really
want
and we have a way to do this now um
uh using the consumerized docutools but
this is the way to do it
using our fancy docutools is to say
template input
oh for goodness freaking sake that's the
right font but
it's gone crazy and it's got links and
things in there
well okay so this is this is a thing as
a matter of fact in our
sort of process of writing these kinds
of essays this is something we need to
provide
as a as an easy thing to do because this
is this is what we do in our own
documentation
we are always doing this yeah it's
impacted by this different style sheets
so we'll make a note of that
right but so so the point here is what
are we doing here
what we're doing is this is not a piece
of
raw native code because p and q are sort
of dummy variables
so we really want these to be italic
just like
in if i look up you know the the actual
and this probably should be a link here
um
and again that should be something
that's easy to get to but
um let me let me just show you what i
mean here
if i go to the page about and um
what we'll see here let me go to a
different page which
isn't quite so oh well this is okay
um
okay so the point is those that is
in the code font but
oh gosh this is a silly page to look at
let me let me look at some other page
um so something like this nest and the
brackets and the commas and so on are in
the code font
but these f expert n are an italic font
indicating that they're kind of dummy
objects where you can fill anything in
there
and we need an easy way to do that for
these essays
okay let me let me keep going though um
so i'm gonna just sort of hack this font
here
but this is something that should be you
know should be part of the
sort of exposition making palette or
or whatever else or possibly even this
is something
yeah i don't know exactly how to get to
it okay a basic example of boolean
function
is and alternatively
uh um
let's see um
okay is the standard logical operation
logic operation and
and um
essentially uh
let's see the value of and
let's see the thing i'm grappling with
is if i say and
and doesn't represent both p
and q are true
um
he ethan is asking why aren't you using
the essay notebook template
that is a very good question and i'm
embarrassed
that we're not okay here we go where is
it
repository adam this is
absurd that we're not using this why are
we not using this
it's it's in the agenda that i made
and why am i getting some stupid error
here
a string or task object is expected
instead of dollar
failed
why am i getting that i don't know the
answer but i'll follow up on it
it's kind of super annoying yeah not
seeing that
i think i got it too and there's some
paclet that needs to be updated
but i don't remember why or what
you got it separately for something else
no exactly here for this i think
yeah i think that you had to do the a
resource update
um exactly yeah that was it
okay that was a very good comment and
good catch and i really don't like the
color of that heading but okay it's a
different story
the sort of brown heading is kind of
rather unattractive
all right let's let's use our own dog
food here
let's correctly use this
oh what the hell happened there i was
copy pasting into that cell
what the hell did it do i think it's
crazy
i think i know what happened and it's
wrong
yeah i think i had the same thing
happened to me when i used this also i
believe i reported it
so it was a certain selection that did
that what the hell is this doing
what's this doing come on guys you got
to get this to work properly
what is this doing get rid of those
stupid eyes and just
make the thing actually work right
it's no good if that if that thing
interferes with
it's lovely it's yeah it's not the eye
that's lovely and it's irrelevant
it's not the either how do i get rid of
it i think how do i get rid of that
you should be able to select it and
delete it
well i can't maybe i can but no i can't
i can't delete that
so get rid of that it should be
deletable
well we typically make things
undeletable if there's structural
requirements or things but they're not i
mean somebody who's
i don't want to see something which
looks like it's some analog of a
trademark
sign well okay that was a design that
was settled on sometime
but it's relevant for other kinds of
things but not for this
this is much more of a narrative essay
yes
okay so here i don't know what the
abstract is yet
um
i mean the abstract could be this but i
don't think it is that
um
i'm really this these eyes are going to
make me too annoyed i don't think i'm
going to deal with this
make you cross-eyed yeah
um and we do have them on other forms
and maybe we don't
on other ones or you're thinking maybe
just this one
i think it's just this one because
you're writing narrative text i mean
these other ones you're writing small
amounts of text as documentation to
support something else
um
i mean okay so a thing that we're
missing here is the ability to make this
template input
thing that is this mixture of of you
know
something like this right okay i mean i
would just lose all of these silly eyes
here
and look because this is so much an
ordinary piece of text
if you don't know how to write this you
you are
you know up the creek no paddles no way
to swim
nothing yeah i'm a firm believer in the
linked example you know explaining
everything
or you know template i think so yeah
right but i mean the main point is
this is like word processing this is
like a word processor a word processor
is not going to give you
an information thing for every line you
type right
i mean it's very different from
something where you've got a structured
thing
where there are five different kinds of
things where it's a form this isn't
really a form it's not a form
right right right um well these are easy
updates to make and to pack that update
and then i'll i'll talk with the
the team about what these documentation
tools are and
and
all right so we didn't have an abstract
here
and i don't know
let's keep going a bit without an
abstract and let's see how we how we do
here
um
by the way nick is asking why is there
no way to have an inline
code cell inside a text cell
yeah that's actually a
completely sensible question right why
can't you do that
are you referring to to documentation
structures again when you say no no
we're saying what nick is saying is
you know if i say something like the cat
nest fx3 okay
and now i want this to be oops
i want that um
i want this thing here i can make it be
static
styled text okay but what i can't do
is make that be an inline cell that
is i mean there's no technical reason
why you can't have an inline cell here
so if i do well we have inline math
cells so inline code cells make perfect
sense
yes they do and the point being made is
why don't we have those
because if i do this here this will be a
math cell by default
right but the question is how would i
make that be a code cell
and we should have that i can pass that
along
and possibly we can do it with some kind
of shift you know i don't know whether
it makes sense
i'm not quite sure what you mean by math
cell it is inline
it is box data it is not i know it's
particularly
helpful it's traditional form well
traditional form no
no no inline math is not traditional
okay but it's it's got italic variables
it's got all kinds of stuff like that
right yeah and and what what we're
asking for here
is i want to show something there that
is a piece of code
that i might type in either with or
without syntax coloring
right yeah and that's what we're talking
about i think it'd be nice to have some
text coloring probably there
because i think there's no reason why
you'd want to turn off syntax coloring
if you have syntax coloring for the
whole document um
well again with our docs we do this
that's what the control t
feature does you know so same difference
really
yeah okay fair enough boy ethan is
asking for something new and different
that i've never seen before
he's asking for grammarly integration
for notebooks
wowie pretty soon
you don't need a human to write stuff
you can just have the machine learning
system you want um hey andre why is
inline math cells having the same font
as the text
text fonts now uh that was
a decision you know we want if it's
in line to text it should pick up from
the text
i hate it i hate it i hate it i always
hated it
i know your guy who says it says math
type setting
only uses one style of font right a
certain type of serif look
uh i get that but that's not the
ultimate theory of how type settings
should work
this for example we'll now use oh there
is an ultimate theory
there there is a graphic that there's a
graphic designers and book
uh typesetters theory of how photography
works but uh it you know
anybody who wants to bring their own
math biases to it can have a different
take i i can't argue with
that you know um
so you know this is some that's
debatable it's something that maybe
we're saying needs to be more easily
configurable for people
because when we say traditional form we
do mean about the way the constructs
are put together how you know
the the actual structure of the typeset
content is positioned and whatever
it doesn't necessarily have to imply oh
and it's typeset in something that looks
like a
an old serif you know
font from books uh that okay
there's a bunch of there's a bunch of
stuff here about the ability to have
inline cells
that are themed for math themed for code
and
theme for this thing that we currently
have inline cells themed for
and that's something we need to deal
with but we were you know
the purpose of this discussion was was
as much about content as about form
okay actually a cute thing that we
developed which we haven't really used
is inline plots so there is a theme
called inline and it literally makes a
plot the size that you could have in a
piece of text
yeah well that's i mean i i certainly
put plots
in text and they and then i typically
resize them by hand
right and this does other things too
there's a lot of decorations in a full
detail in a full-size plot
inline it's not listed there yeah it's
eventually
it's not one of them it's not auto
completing there's something wrong it's
not auto completing that
that doesn't mean it's wrong it's wrong
it should be auto completing if it
exists as a plot theme it should be auto
completing
something didn't get connected between
the auto completer and the list of
possible plot themes
just run it
that's cool i've never seen that before
that's very cool and it has to write
baseline
so if i take that and i put it in
there that's beautiful cut
please did somebody note down i noted it
and i will report it yeah
okay that's very nice roger well maybe
we'll get to use that in this
in this essay not sure okay let's come
back to the text
um uh flippy
is on the live stream is is making
comments about digital gates and so on
unfortunately there's so many different
words that i think
um
are implemented as an and gate
and digital electronics
again one has to be a little bit careful
here because if you have
so much throat clearing here people have
forgotten what the point is before you
actually get to say what the point is
okay um
in its simplest form
and takes
two boolean
variables say p
and q and
um oh god
horrifying boots and and and and
here
we could use to avoid this we could use
okay so the trade-off is
we use all we're going to have the same
mess here
um
and um uh but if we use nand
then people don't know what it is right
so i don't think there's any boolean
function
which both isn't used as a
where people both understand what it is
and where people don't use it as a
conjunction in ordinary language
anybody got any thoughts about that
see okay let me make a meta comment this
is incredibly typical
in exposition that there's this kind of
puzzle you've got you know these
different pieces you've got these
different objectives
and the question is can you satisfy all
those objectives
this makes sense to people
yep okay
so i mean in this case anybody got any
suggestions for what to do here anybody
here
yes we're here we're watching we're
listening thinking okay
is this a okay in simplest form
and takes two boolean variables say p
and q
and
and with the value
well i'm saying and determines whether
quotes both p and q
are true
and
and it's result and it's
takes two boolean variables say p and q
and gives the result
and gives us a result
how about giving the result i i'm just
trying to but
if you avoid using the word hand yeah
yeah right
right right right right
we get slightly more technical and say
returns true
if both people because then
well we could do that maybe no we
haven't said
true unfortunately we haven't given
because we've given several alternatives
here
for what these things
are operating on okay
whereas here
takes two billion variables say p and q
and
um
see one of the things that's tricky is
it sounds like this only gives a result
if both b and q are true like
if they're not both true it goes off
into la la land and does nothing
rather than it gives false
well okay you know what maybe you're
right and gives
true
in the case which both values are true
well we could say if both p and q are
true
and false otherwise
um not great
uh it's two billion variables say p and
q and gives true of both
and false otherwise so now what we might
do i'm not
super happy with this so now we'd say
um
might it help if even earlier we say
a boolean variable is either true or
false
see the problem with that is
you know what you're building up to is a
giant piece of throat clearing
which is the typical way mathematical
stuff is written and most people lose it
before before you get to the payload
so to speak so in other words you have
to try and minimize the amount of
you know let's define this to be that
let's define this to be that
um
i think we might i think we'll be okay
with this because what people are then
going to look at
is um let's see so here
um
i'm not real happy with this because i'm
i'm kind of wondering
um what's tricky about what we're doing
here
is what we're about to build up to is
something like
and of p of or of q
and you know q and r or something
okay the problem with that is
that that's really a little different
than just saying
you know a boolean table
just just defining a function by
what is essentially i mean not to not to
make it too um
i don't know you know something like um
uh
you know something like this which is a
representation of a boolean function of
three variables
and maybe we can say i mean here
actually we could just say boolean
function i think
right so at some point we can just give
that so what is the one for and
uh what is the boolean um
it is one one one
zero which is otherwise known
as 14.
but i'm not mistaken um what am i
talking about come on guys are you guys
awake or not
this is obviously wrong right so this is
that's and right
i don't know that there are other ca
experts here
it's not a cellular automaton thing
anybody here who understands
you i mean you understand what's going
on here there's two inputs here there's
one output
true true gives true true falsehood
so yes that seems that appears to be
rather representation of and as eight
okay all right um guys if we're going to
have so many people here we need a
little bit more interactivity
so steven do you think like you know
focusing on developing the text
is the first step or just coding and
then basically
write the text
because that that's what's giving you
you just write a bunch of code
and then you know sometimes there'll be
something where you have to solve a
difficult code problem
right um
uh well i i think what maz is getting at
is
do you flesh this out with an outline of
all the text first and then come back or
do
you stick with do it
if you try and do that it'll it'll fail
horribly
you have to write the whole knitted
thing in one go
you can't expect to do you know write
all the text
then fill in the pictures type thing the
only thing that i do that with when i
write is links
okay i do not put the links in in the
initial writing effort
you know i go back for that but
everything else i'm doing in one one
pass here
um
let's see okay so
hmm this is difficult here what to do
here
uh
because
you know the other thing we could do
which i think is a bit obscure
is you know something like this
see what i'm saying because otherwise
this is in a sense too simple and it's
hard to tell what's going on
you could create a matrix plot of the
values with all different true false
things to
demonstrate or something like the rule
plot could work and give a better
example of all possibilities
yes the matrix one isn't going to work
well initially
because that that's that's requires you
to understand
i mean if if we make that that's going
to be you know an array plot
of um what is that is that boolean table
what is the array plot roger do you know
roger are you here yeah what um
yeah so i'm asking you what is the okay
so it's this
which is the same you're gonna have to
partition it so if you go to boolean
function neat examples or
uh you'll find examples of that
but you basically have to build the
matrix
and then well so okay so maybe the
better way to do that is to say
table see the problem is okay so first
thing is
to get that into true false we have to
say bool of that
which is not i'm sorry into one zero we
have to say bool of that otherwise we
can't
well actually the other way to do it
better way to do this would be the
following
doesn't matter for a rate plot but yeah
well it will matter we have to say
color map you know true color rules two
goes to one that's a true goes to black
et cetera right right but it will do
something i mean it's sort of set up to
deal with
all kinds of crap is it set up to deal
with this case
yeah no it's not no it's not
okay so so let's look here
what we probably want is to say table
and p
q p true false
and then q true false
okay now we would say array plot but
this is getting a little complicated
here
true goes to black whoops color rules
true goes to black
false goes to white and then we got yet
another thing here then we've got to say
mesh goes to true
okay and that will be our our
multiplication table effectively and
what we might do here
is to iconize that
um and nick is pointing out that in the
function repository
there's a decently nice function
that gives um
let's see here
there's a decently nice function for
truth tables here which is probably
doing what wolfman alpha does for a
tooth table
what's it doing
that's extremely elaborately complicated
i mean it's kind of nice
i like the fourth of july colors
i'm rolling my eyes
okay so let's go back here
to the problem of how we get started
here because the problem is
in my view that is in a sense too simple
an example
and it doesn't reveal what's going on
see what i'm saying
right i think i'm not having i'm having
a hard time this is not particularly
useful
i can just sit here and write this
myself but if we're doing this
as a interactive discussion gotta have
more interaction
okay so you understand the problem the
problem is if we give too simple a
boolean function here um
well okay so one thing we could do i
sent in chat and this is under
applications for boolean function
a way to enumerate all of them and plot
all of them using array plot
yeah okay well that's nice all two
variables and all three variable
functions yeah
i understand that's nice and worth
having um
yeah and there's a similar you know you
can i understand
i understand i mean that that to me is a
more advanced thing because then what
we're going to do
is eventually we're going to show
functional completeness of nand and so
on
okay but we're having a hard time
getting started here okay so
um uh
because what we've got to explain is
that one of these pictures represents
all possible inputs right
i had a slightly hard time with this
because the notion the word
function people will think algebra
calculus
whatever and they'll think f of x
you know they're used to x being
continuous variable they're not used to
saying
there are four cases x equals zero you
know x and y
one and zero did you get what i'm saying
why not mentioning that explicitly like
reminding the user but
but because because then
we just blew up the possibility
that anybody who doesn't already know
calculus can understand what we're
talking about
do you see what i'm saying so you've got
to think about what is the
you know what's the dependency stack of
the things you're talking about here
i know but a function is basically a
table the fact that we don't show it as
a table
seems okay no it's not a table the
person who learnt
functions in calculus didn't learn
functions as a table
now maybe they should have done but they
didn't they learned functions as you
know sign
so they've learned continuous tables but
so yes i understand but
the the jump from a continuous table to
a table
is an unjumpable jump for most people
right so i think we might be better off
so what i was thinking is maybe we
should jump directly into pictures
and show things like this but then i'm
worried
that um
see i was thinking we would talk about f
of x but i'm worried about that because
i don't think
like like in my whole eiwl book about
you know elementary introduction to
wolfram language i did not mention
functions in the sense of calculus you
know f of x is sine x
at all ever because
my experience and observation is people
do not understand that stuff until
they've done like pre-calculus or
something
i i mean do you understand what i'm
saying
i mean maybe they understand it also
from computers from
you know a function definition but again
people are kind
of confused by that too
so ok
well maybe we can say
here is a pictorial representation
of a simple
boolean function
now then what we would do here which
again i'm not quite sure whether this is
the right way to do it is a folded up
thing like this
um the
the top row represents the input
bottom row the output
um black
squares represent true
white squares false
um
the okay so
um
in the first box
well let's see
top row represents
the input to boolean function is a
collection of values so i'm defining the
input to be the collective
thing not there are two inputs here i
could equally well have said there are
two inputs here
but i'm not doing that i'm saying
there's input which is
the collective thing
um
the boolean function
shown here corresponds to
is and if
both
[Music]
see i want to get the word and this is
what i'm struggling with
i don't want to say if both input
if both elements what i might say if
both
elements of the input are true
the result is true
otherwise it is false okay i don't like
that because i would really love to use
the word
and since i said this is the and
function
communicating that idea with code isn't
it easier
just showing the code or what is the
code
just for example and yeah that that one
the simple one yes
no we can show that next but but we
gotta say
how about if we did or if both
if no then we're gonna have either
so i'm saying um
okay here's the hack if the first
and second elements
are both true the result is true
otherwise it is false
we remove a level of confusion by
instead of using
black and white literally print the
words true and false
in the image not a terrible idea
um i think that image will be so ugly if
we do that though
that and also the code necessary to
produce the image will be kind of messy
i mean i was gonna get back to that
truth table resource function
that's i think a lot of people are used
to that that
something like that is gonna remove the
necessity to explain
what is white what is black what's top
row
well okay fair enough fair enough there
we go okay fair enough
um but then we've got to explain the p
and q notation there
that that you had it in a parent
i know but but i i think that this is a
rather daunting
thing here there's a lot going on in
this image
right in other words if somebody if you
say and if if you change that to
and p comma q is that gonna persist
you mean here yes
i don't know that i don't know what that
did but but
yes i mean the reason i say there's a
lot going on in this image
okay somebody who is confronted with
this image at the very beginning
will i'm afraid switch off
because understanding what's happening i
mean this isn't super difficult to
understand but
but it's still
i mean for example i would argue that a
better presentation here would have been
to gray down the left hand side
so that you see the main event is just
true false false false
making sense because otherwise otherwise
cognitively
you've got basically uh
you know you've got your um 12 boxes
here and it's like what the heck's going
on 12 boxes there's a
thick line there's a thin line there's
colors there's differing alignments
yeah i mean there's just a lot of weird
stuff going on and
um this uh
is um um
yeah i mean as people are suggesting
here having a legend that says
um you know true
i mean i have to say i don't think
people get very confused by this kind of
representation
and the point is from this picture it
gives you the
sense that you will understand it
because it's a fairly simple picture
um now
we're then going down the path so by the
way roger if i take p
and q so if i if i have a boolean a pure
function
okay can i do this can i say um
boolean function of the
pure function
p q r let's say
um p
and q or r does that work
no how do i do that how do you
how do you discover what number it is or
what you mean yes
yes that's right okay okay let me
figure that out i can't remember
okay but i mean so this is a possible
approach that what we fundamentally
do it's a bit cellular automatonistic
but um
although you know these diagrams by the
way
you know maybe i'm just so used to them
after 40 years of using them that they
seem totally obvious to me but i found
in thousands of talks and so on that
people do seem to get the idea of these
diagrams fairly easily
um and and to me you know
you understand why i'm saying this
diagram is much more appealing than this
thing here
this thing here might be easier to
explain what's that yeah i agree
but then you need the text definitely to
explain what that is
it's like specifying your notations if
you want to start with the notation
and then explain what that is once
that's fine too
yeah actually i agree i i think you need
something with the text at least first
and then then you bring all the people
along who aren't used to seeing it
displayed as black and white squares
right but i mean and i think
if if you're setting up some guidelines
it wouldn't be bad to say
how the notations should be set up up
right
at the beginning maybe a section for
notations would be nice in the
template notebook well the problem with
that though
is if you say preamble notation
right in this document
as we go forward with this it's going to
get you know more and more things are
going to happen and there's eventually
going to be fairly sophisticated
i mean easy from the wolfram language
point of view difficult
from the traditional math notation point
of view
you know as we start looking at um uh so
i don't
i mean if you're suggesting that we have
a preamble which specifies notation i
don't think that's going to work very
well
i was suggesting that now i agree how
about something like a side note that
says
this is a definition of how we are
showing the concept or how we are
writing the concept
some kind of an inner interlude
in the set of all things we might write
about we picked one where this is
uniquely difficult
usually this is not a big issue the
reason this is difficult
is because there's a collision of plain
english language
and the code and the math and what we're
showing it's all so simple
that it's hard to tell what's going on
now
it won't be as simple as soon as we get
to a function even
p and q or r as soon as we get to
something like
that it's already much more
understandable
see the problem is okay in general
talking about boolean functions we're
going to end up with two different
branches one is essentially the
algebraic representation of boolean
function in terms of p
and q or r in a sense what we're going
to do what we're going to have to talk
about here
is the sort of the the you know the
quotes
the formula representation
and the tabular representation
those are the two things we're going to
end up with and then what we're going to
say is
given a tabular representation you can
always get a formula
and what we're going to say is you know
what um
what elements do we need
in the formula so that we can
get all possible functions
i.e all possible tables
and that's our functional completeness
and so on
for um uh you know that's that's how we
diff you know how we get to functional
completeness for nand
um there's a properties and relations
thing from boolean function that
gives you that i pasted it into chat
okay
that gives you the number the index
oh i see that's an obvious way to do it
with bullying table yes i get it
um and
kevin is sending through
you yeah
i mean this isn't bad
this is a useful thing to show along the
way i mean so again
what we're going to see here and i think
this is a feature of this particular
example
is we're going to see five different
representations
of what's going on and the question then
is how many of them to show because
the thing we absolutely don't want is to
show this one
and this one and this one it's like
that's just total
irreducible confusion you know we gotta
stick to something but we might be able
to show
two for instance um
okay so we're probably going to have to
wrap for right now in a moment but but
but you understand where we where we're
kind of going is
conceptually right when we talk about
boolean functions
they're really these two different ways
of thinking about them this formula
version and the tabular version
does that make sense to people that is
just the table of the you know the truth
table
and the thing represented as f of
f and uh you know p and q
or blah blah blah blah blah right so
then a thing we're going to talk about
is
there's a formula representation there's
a tabular representation
eg in the formula representation we can
do the equivalent of algebra we can do
algebra uh which happens to be boolean
algebra
does this make sense to people yes
[Music]
and uh you know in the tabular
representation
we can well again there
you know the question is if we want to
then we've got to say
when we implement in a digital circuit
it's like the formula representation
you know where the functions
are gates and the variables
are effectively are like wires but we
have to say that more carefully um
yeah so comment from eric about throwing
in you might want to use the wedge and
the v and so on yes yes yes yes yes
i suspect we'll get the wedge in the v
because we'll have a table at some point
that just shows all the boolean
functions and the interpretation of all
of them which i think is useful
um
uh super is saying here i think you're
underestimating people's ability to
understand
if they don't understand even understand
the basics it's even worth trying to
explain
to them yes i think that if you do it
this is the trick
in explaining i mean i i i humbly
consider myself pretty good at this
particular
um thing
um
the uh of of being able to
find these paths that allow one to
explain really quite complicated things
you know the the challenge in explaining
complicated things
without losing people who don't
already have you know some fraction of
the knowledge
the ch there's two challenges one is
you can end up you know getting to the
point where you explain to the
five-year-old
how to do you know certain pieces of
calculus
and yes you can make it work but it's
incredibly fragile
that is you you've ended up with you
know this tiny
uh path um
uh from you know from what you can
explain to some results
and as soon as you perturb that path
it's like total lack of understanding
the trick is to give people you know a
reasonably robust understanding which
makes use of and this is the challenge
it is very minimalist it makes use of as
few concepts
as possible but on the other hand has to
it has to put its feet down in concepts
that people understand and one trick
here
which we're sort of using here is
there are terms that people have heard
of like digital electronic devices what
is the definition of that
not everybody will know the definition
of that whatever it might be
but it kind of gives some theming
background to what an earth we're
talking about here
um and clearly you know
there's a good guess that i mean
somebody might have sort of heard of a
boolean function
but only have a very vague sense of what
it is
um i think uh so anyway i mean i i think
it's
it's some um um
let's see okay we got a couple more
comments on live stream here from dan
digital circuit representation i think
will be illustrated as a direct
application of boolean algebra
yes i mean yes but
you got to understand wires you've got
to understand
see the problem with the boolean circuit
i mean yes you can
represent you can use the circuit as a
piece of data flow
you cannot use the circuit as a
representation of voltages
in other words a data flow thing which
shows you know essentially the graph
that shows that this i don't know how we
would generate the graph from this how
would we generate the graph from this
you know what i'm saying it's it's like
in fact here's here's what we could do
we could just
say expression tree
and we'll have essentially i mean that
would probably be a useful
representation at some point to show
here that that is um
uh and that's
uh let's see what i mean the problem is
okay so the difficulty here is
let's say this was uh you know r
and p for example um we'll end up with
this
where those p's are the same p so to
speak
and whether that's explainable or not
i'm not sure
but um um you know i think we'll be able
to get a fair distance i mean
my guess is we'll be able to get boolean
simplification we'll probably be able to
get satisfiability
to explain that we can explain
functional completeness i would predict
that we will be able to explain all of
these things
at a below precalculus level
and um uh but on the other hand the
other thing one's got to do
you know the real trick in a lot of
these explanational things
is how do you give an explanation
that doesn't have the people who already
know it just sort of
falling asleep rolling their eyes um
but nevertheless not lose the people who
don't already know it
and so uh and also not have the people
already know it
be like scratching your head saying
that's a really weird way to explain
this
um but i think by things like uh you
know
what you want is the people already know
it to be like oh yeah
that's a nice way to explain that um
without this being oh i'm bored and and
preferably to say oh that's a nice way
to explain it i'll use that way to
explain it next time i have to explain
to somebody
um and
uh ethan is suggesting that we ask
various experts to do this yeah it'd be
interesting to do i mean look this is a
okay we're gonna have to wrap up in a
moment here but but um
uh and we will continue this at another
time and i i was just not
at all prepped for this particular thing
and again we should consider it
continue it in an unprepped way um
but uh you know
i think perhaps it's useful for those
who are
you know you know i i do realize as i
try and
explain how to do this one that there's
an awful lot of different
things you have to juggle to make one of
these expositions work
um and uh um
and perhaps that's why these are not as
easy as um i mean
i kind of think of them as quotes easy
but i know that in this intro
it will take me like 15 minutes to get a
reasonable intro to this thing
at the end i'll probably have a pretty
reasonable intro where
again the the real challenge is can you
absolutely minimize the number of
concepts you need to use
but nevertheless give enough
uh sort of attachment points to things
people already know and mentioning words
people
already know so that they're not like
what on earth are these people talking
about so to speak
so anyway the uh
so rbs is commenting against tap water
that flows down tubes and show logic
operations like that
right i mean that's that's like fluidic
logic i mean i think a good thing to do
instead of the one section here will be
to say what are different implementation
forms
and you can talk about fluidic logic you
can talk about um
i mean you know okay so there's stretch
things here like reversible boolean
functions and so on
um but uh you know what we'd want to do
is show a really complicated boolean
function and show what it corresponds to
in terms of its multiplication table
it's some um yeah a bunch of different
things here
um yeah this is the
actually this was a pretty good choice
of a topic
because it is difficult because it is so
comparatively elementary
yet it accelerates quite quickly out of
the purely elementary
and my claim is that we will be able to
carry people along
even if they're only at the precalculus
level uh we shall see
um all right any other comments um uh
as we're um just to to wrap up for today
if not i gotta go yep all right okay
thanks
thanks thanks everybody folks on
livestream we will continue